at Americana remember when they St LA
and they just they're basically like
takeovers yeah yeah everybody just runs
in grabs everything and runs out and
like you know those people who are
working there it's not on themom T I'm
trying to figure out when the next one
is which group chat is
[Music]
it hey did you guys hear about the uh
UPS how like UPS drivers yes
170k dude they're killing it so it's
been like report that uh the union
struck a deal um and UPS drivers are now
going to make up to 170k a year good for
them dude they're the they're very nice
people do you think it's true I like
them I think it's true because then
prices are going to go up for shipping
now ooh interesting I feel like we're I
don't even know the cost gets passed
down to
you can't wait is there if it's
sustainable to do it that way yeah is
there a reason why
um delivery services but specifically
UPS over like other things DHL FedEx
USPS or whatever like receive such a
high salary the union the union they
argue a good yeah they they got it but
it's not exactly
170k equivalent yeah it's like your your
uh your insurance your benefits your
pensions it what it what it means is
that it would rival a 170k a year job
like you'd have to have a 170k a year
job to take you away from UPS
that's still good cuz I mean like you
don't need a college degree for ups and
if you no you have to have a master's if
you're if you're just working as a
driver and then and then if you you know
like some people like they're like I
don't want to keep getting promoted like
I'm just I like just being a driver
right and then you can have like a
stable job for the rest of your life
yeah so I asked my I have a friend who's
been working at UPS for quite a while
and I asked him to uh like tell me
something something that they're not
writing about in all the Articles like
why about the 170k thing this is what he
told me oh he did it voice yeah he sent
me a voice message okay so here's the
thing our contract everyone's saying
170,000 that is absolute unless
you're maybe a semi-truck driver for UPS
those guys can get up there cuz they're
pretty much getting paid the entire time
they're driving from but and Egypt
to California and back the whole time um
downside obviously they don't get to see
their family and then uh is he on a
shift right now for me that high pay and
everything like that we're not going to
see that till
2027 that's the one thing that they
don't say uh on the
contract they're just we have a
progression so it's like we're going to
get up to $49 an hour at 2027 that makes
sense but there's no guarantee that
we're going to get enough hours to get
that the only way to possibly get close
to $170,000 in a year is if we're
working 6 days a week at our maximum
amount of hours that California can let
us work which is 14 hours a
day um and even then that's pushing it
like there's no it's I don't think it's
possible like you get literally got to
have no life to make that
money but yeah at the end of the day um
you know if you do see me with a new car
cardier bracelet you
know that wasn't from
UPS package
baby then he he added something else
right here oh and another thing cuz a
lot of people that I've been hearing
about talking about it they're like oh I
can just imagine now how much shipping
is going to cost um UPS has always been
overcharging for shipping um obviously
maybe don't play that part out
loud yeah they've always charged a lot
so and since the beginning of
Co they what a gangster saved and made
so much money off of us new drivers that
came in because we were pretty much the
discount version of what we're where
we're supposed to be at now that's a big
detail so they made billions upon
billions upon billions of
and they didn't even want to give it
back to their members they ended up
giving it to the stock shareholders
and everybody kind of was pissed so
that's why our contract this time around
we were willing to just strike and
pretty much destroy UPS to get what we
wanted damn that last part so what's
being done here is it's reparations for
something that they did was unjust to
the
worky they felt bad and you don't see
that written
anywhere I mean why would you this is
like the prime example of like a good
headline and people just go off of the
headline yeah and instead it's like
attracting people to work for UPS but
they're not actually going to get this
as easily as yeah for
sure you know when you see like those
videos of uh like Amazon delivery
drivers and stuff like that that are
just getting looted yeah they
got a they got a sh they got a in
the bucket yeah like that's are
those different
issues
I was like what are you talking about
looted from bad guys cuz I was thinking
about looted from Amazon cuz like their
hours are so hardcore that to make their
like demands they have to pissing
in the bucket in their in their dve got
it yeah that's exactly what I was saying
except the other one they don't have
time to do a bathroom break so they're
being looted by like Heist people yeah
when you just see like a bunch of people
in hoods like run up to a event and then
they just like overwhelm that one driver
and they're just jacking everything off
the bus ah like that's where I'm like
all right yeah you need to pay these
drivers cuz like they're like safety or
whatever's on the line and if they they
they're getting backed with the salad
then they need to like protect their
goods you know Hazard pay whenever you
guys drive whenever you guys drive by an
Amazon truck do you think like man I
could just run in there and take
whatever I want no you need like you
need like 60 people to do it all at once
no of course you got a crew of course
you got a crew they you see that's been
going on around a lot right like
freaking people going I mean even at the
like everyone of the St at
Americana when they St me and
they just they're basically like
takeovers yeah yeah everybody just runs
in grabs everything runs out and like
you know those people who are working
there it's not on them from to I'm
trying to figure out when the next one
is which group chat is it you guys you
guys are need a 62 guy don't play into
your stereotype here like I don't I mean
I think it's up but at the same
time I'm like that is kind of smart cuz
when I was that age like to organize a
smash and grab dude how many people
could I have convinced to bum rush a
store and just grab everything together
and Just
Bounce like kids were doing crime all
like forever but they've been stealing
independently these guys are organizing
40 50 people together and all doing it
like I'm not here giving them props but
I'm just saying like I could tap into
that mentality when I was their age
honestly yeah like if I in the ruffian I
could see that being I could see it
making logical sense no we were like
walking up and like you got it all right
be my Lookout all right let's go I feel
like it's like the ding-dong ditch era
of like of now pretty much yeah but like
you know it's I'm not I'm not trying to
like side with the bad guys but at the
same time when shit's like difficult
when the cost of living is rising when
your salar is aren rising when like the
economy is getting over because
of like poor governmental choices like
you're just pushing people into a corner
you know like it's not even just people
just like stealing like high fashioned
designer pieces it's people like
stealing groceries from grocery stores
and organizing those in order to make
sure that your community is being fed
you know what I'm saying kind of is kind
of is probably going to get worse before
it gets better was the last time you
stole something me stealing hearts baby
I how much of that I don't like that
answer you're too good yeah I wonder how
much of that is just youth boredom how
much of that is necessity how much of
that is just like youth anger towards
Society you know like cuz yeah there are
different reasons why people jack
cuz they're greedy or like you know like
some people just want to jack and
then like people just cpto some people
have intrusive thoughts and they want to
live it out I guess I guess that's the
thing it's like if you're mobbing then
you have everyone for every reason doing
it together it's like you could probably
find somebody in there that needed it
you can find someone who just wanted to
have fun like of course but then you're
right it is the it's like the Battle
Royale version of like individual
jacking you know what I mean it's like
hey at least let's get a Lobby together
30 people and then we can and then we
can we can steal larger volumes and
better items and then we can start a
militia together yeah so it's not all
Claire's belts and Claire's belt I
think regardless of motive it's still
theft right oh yeah it's still like bad
for society but also Society is bad
generally right now so you know and I
think like at least it was consequences
for our us like we all knew if we're
doing it something's going to happen I
think that's the difference is like well
someone was going to chase you at least
you can't chase you can't chase anymore
now no one's doing yeah everyone
watching recording yeah but that's the
thing though it's it's the the
litigation climate that we're in nobody
wants to be liable for something right
but if it's that if it's that like you
don't have any consequences right that
wouldn't that drive someone who is like
you know what what I always wanted to
steal something but now I won't get in
trouble so maybe I'll just take that
purse I think about it all the time and
might drive people who never would have
stolen well they caught they caught two
people from that uh Americana uh oh they
did they caught two of them but they
released them yeah they released them
the same day and with a citation yeah
it's just a catch a release in my head I
I fantasize about this all the time yeah
that's why I'm like honestly I'm
inspired to just Jack some
too like cuz why not when I see that
Snickers bar just keep it under 9 50
that's all you got to do but after you
see that and nothing happens doesn't
that make you just go why am I working
hard to be
honorable why I want to be a crook so
bad dude you want to know what really
like broke my heart to be honest
so like this happened in Downey at the
mall in Downey recently where they uh
Smash and grab the jewelry store there
my I showed my mom cuz like my mom lives
in Downey and then she goes oh um that's
the Jeweler that your dad saved up to
buy our engag engagement ring oh my gosh
my dad saved for like years to afford
the ring like from his job back when
like in the 80 or '70s and then that
Jeweler like used to be outside the mall
and then like they moved and then my mom
was just watching it like that's so sad
like to think that to think that we
could have just jacked
it all those Wasted
Years all we had to do is get a group of
people together oh it was that easy yeah
he didn't have to work so hard that's
why you got to have friends you got to
have a community of friends right they
educate you on stuff like this yeah for
real JK takeover let's do
it